things are heating up between kim
kardashian and pete davidson
yes a source tells e.t the two are
casually dating and seeing where things
go quote pete is really into kim and
excited about her kim likes pete as well
but isn't rushing into anything serious
it's a different experience for sure
meanwhile another source tells e.t kim
has been protective of her ex kanye west
and his feelings adding that she's been
trying to keep her hangouts with pete
low key because she doesn't know how
kanye will react i'm just extremely
happy can you tell by my face
an additional source tells e.t
kim and kanye's co-parenting
relationship and friendship changes
almost daily depending on kanye's mood
one day he wants to get back together
with kim and the next day he is blocking
her number kim is over any drama
at the end of the day life is about
being happy
this all comes on the heels of the 41
year old's kkw beauty founder and the 27
year old saturday night live star having
dinner together last week in staten
island just days after they were first
seen holding hands on a roller coaster
halloween weekend at not scary farm at
the time a source told et quote kim and
pete like each other they are trying to
play it off that they are just friends
but it's a little more than that right
now they're having a lot of fun together
pete makes kim laugh and makes her feel
special pete is obviously thrilled and
has a major crush on kim
and shortly after all that kanye's
appearance on revolts podcast drink
champs dropped and he made it clear he
wants his estranged wife back
snl making my wife say i divorced him on
tv because they just wanted to get that
bar off and i ain't never even seen the
papers we're not even divorced
so how we
because that ain't no joke to me of
course kim filed for divorce back in
february and when the reality star
hosted saturday night live last month
she addressed their split during her
opening monologue
when i divorced him you have to know it
came down to just one thing
his personality
i know that sounds mean but people keep
telling me that comedy comes from truth
and if there's one thing that i always
strive to be it's genuine one person
who's not laughing kanye
my kids want their parents to stay
together i want their parents i want us
to be together but if you like me
together too if you look at the media
that's not what they promoting
that's not what they want they want it
to be a new way wedding a new episode a
new tv show and then they had people all
around and my wife here you know this is
publicist that's next to her i don't
[ __ ] with her and just in case you
didn't catch his drift kanye double down
i want to pull my family back together
i'm assuming this interview is not that
helpful to that but that's my family
hulu of course after 20 seasons on e the
kardashian jenner family is now gearing
up for their new reality series on hulu
which explains kanye's reference to the
streaming service and while the rapper
may still be calling his ex his quote
wife because she's still my wife it
ain't no it ain't no paperwork over the
weekend the grammy winner was spotted
with model venetria the two were
photographed sitting courtside at the
debut donda academy basketball game in
minneapolis a private non-affiliated
high school in l.a that is dedicated to
developing the next generation of
leaders the 22 year old model also
seemingly attended kanye's sunday
service last week posting this to her
insta story so for now we'll just have
to wait and see what happens with kim
and kanye but let me send you off on a
high note with a little kim and pete
cuteness from their sketch on
snl i mean i like you just the way you
are
now are you gonna kiss me or not
i sure am jasmine
[Applause]
you